more than 4 million doses of covid-19
vaccines have been administered here in
Clark County that is according to the
Southern Nevada Health District but now
there's a new battle over the creation
of those vaccines an attorney
spearheading two lawsuits just filed
today tells me he believes this is the
real story of what the public doesn't
know yet about how the vaccine was
developed
moderna Pfizer and bioentech are accused
of stealing a method to make covid-19
vaccines chromosome LLC a much smaller
biotech Company claims its scientists
including Nobel Laureate Dr Gerald
Edelman first developed the technology
in San Diego County in 2009 and it was
patented in 2014 two separate but
similar lawsuits filed in U.S District
Court Tuesday alleged patent
infringement by the three pharmaceutical
Giants in this first lawsuit chromosome
claims that shared information with
moderna about the method as early as
2013. in this second lawsuit chromosome
claims it disclosed the patented
technology to Pfizer in 2015 but neither
of the companies licensed the technology
the lawsuits point to a combined 110
billion dollars in profits earned by the
three companies from the covid-19
vaccines and they allege reverse
engineering confirms the method was
stolen the the technology centers around
mRNA which according to the complaint
prepares the immune system to fight the
virus without the presence of the virus
now you might be wondering how did they
develop this back in 2009 if the
pandemic began just a few years ago but
again they're talking about part of the
vaccine and a method used to help the
body fight a virus we reached out to the
three defendants for a comment and we
are still waiting for a response